the pod was completely drained the male  victims eyes were held open the pins  the female victim was in his arms  [Music]  someone mutilated her daughter postcard  turned up at a newspaper in Paris and in  Hamburg in the Budapest he announces his  arrival in the city with the postcard  why do you think you posed him he was  saying something this one returns the  kissed Dante and Vergil and helped  Saturn devouring his son they've  discovered a fifth couple of the murders  were exact and purposeful there's a  pattern you've got exactly four days to  prevent a merger I will find the answers  myself I don't recommend you do that you  had your chance I'm gonna copy 30 years  this killers brand of murder is very  specific extremely hard to profile  monsters will remain monsters no matter  what you try to do to tame them it all  makes horrible twisted sense love pain  death they're not finished yet  art is a wound turned into light  you  you